there's been this weird notion of
absolute strangers suddenly pretending
that they care more about you and they
care more about your parents and they
care more about your grandma and your
family than you do which is utterly
absurd these politicians don't care they
don't even know your name
when they know who you are let alone
like your family when these people on
twitter
refer to the unvaccinated as plague rats
and when they say things like you're
stupid you're a [ __ ] and they cheer for
people like joe rogan getting sick
you think i'm supposed to i'm gonna
believe they care about me or anybody
else no no now they're coming out and
straight up saying you know like people
should be denied health care yep i think
they are panicking you you made a pretty
profound point a minute ago when you
were saying that it's like genetically
we're used to this anxiety daily of
surviving and now that there's no it's
like wait i'm supposed to be anxious
about something that builds up and and
these people are
i mean
what what else what they feel like they
are
they're winning they're doing something
to succeed by by this it's something you
know but maybe it is to do nothing i
think you're right ian and i think that
one of the things that we're hugely
lacking in the west because we are so
very lucky like you were saying is any
kind of challenge and zumi and i on the
way down here we're talking about the
men who fought in world war one in world
war ii they're a different kind of
person we have had no such challenges
like they had and it's made us weak it's
made us afraid of things like words
it's made us angry when we don't have
our conveniences
and i think that's probably the root
cause of all of this fear of covid it's
just inconvenient and scary and i was
saying to lydia in that conversation
something that is going on now and this
is again this has been happening for a
couple of decades which is that instead
of trying to make individuals stronger
and more resilient and encouraging them
to be they just try to nerf the whole
world
yeah right so so instead of saying you
know what so so take take the madness
that's been going on with in
universities for the past decade with
safe spaces and trigger warnings and d
platforming speakers and this and that
right the message should be
look guys you got to grow up you got to
live in the world some stuff is going to
offend you you're going to meet people
you disagree with you're going to come
across stuff that are like her and it
might be unpleasant deal with it get
stronger expose yourself deal with it
instead it's like oh no let's wrap
everything in cotton anything that could
be potentially offensive or potentially
harmful they like that word you know
push that away push that away keep
shield them right put them all in a
bubble and then of course when you put
those people out into the real world
where they're no longer protected like
that
it's like it's like an immune system
right they haven't built up that immune
system so when the slightest challenge
comes out they break down and they flip
out and they scream and they call names
and it's almost like dealing with
children yeah absolutely
it's time for one of tim's famous
anecdotes
to explain the situation uh so when i
went on rogan's podcast uh last year
when when cove like it was i came around
i think it was like march drove across
the country i had to get uh covent test
because joe tests everybody and so what
they do is they take some of your blood
from your finger
the lady was trying to use those little
clicker things it's like a little red
thing and they put it on your finger and
they clicked it for me and it they could
she couldn't get it through my calluses
because i played guitar yeah and so
that's the example i'm using for a lot
of these people
in these colleges a lot of these
leftists the reason they're freaking out
and turning like you mentioned like uh
microaggressions into you're erasing my
existence
is they are
they are so pink and and and soft that
if they stepped out into the light they
would immediately their skin would just
start burning in the sun they've not
built up any resilience no so they're
they're just they want everyone else to
i mean cater to their weakness right
instead of them
look you if you want to play the guitar
you you play your you get blisters on
your fingers you you rock stars will
planes all fingers will bleed
imagine these people playing shows
they'd be like just pre-program it for
me because my fingers are soft and they
hurt i ripped the f out of my thumb a
couple nights ago playing the drums that
was awesome think about that concept of
a microaggression
right in a society with macro
aggressions
nobody is concerned about
microaggressions go to any place in the
world where people are actually
suffering and striving for any type of
survival
do you think they're worried about micro
aggressions like that you wouldn't even
be able to explain the concept to them
they just what what are you even talking
right
forget your nonsense i've got stuff to
deal with i'm trying to feed my family
i'm trying to i'm trying to live out
here right you're worried about micro
aggressions um and like
give us an example a good example of
microaggression for people who aren't
familiar
somebody
somebody asking me where i'm really from
[Laughter]
right so if someone asks me where i'm
from and i'm like i'm english and
they're like oh where are you really
from
england right
so that would be a microaggression or
even somebody telling me that i'm
articulate or that i speak well could be
considered a microaggression i'd be like
how right to me that's a compliment
thank you there's there was this viral
video
well thank you yeah right
there was this viral video a long time
ago where it was like an asian woman
jogging and then she like stops to
stretch and there's like a white guy and
they start talking and then he's like so
where are you from and she goes san
francisco and he goes
i mean like where are you from and she's
like
my parents are from korea but the funny
thing is like
considering i'm not a dick
when someone asks me i know they're not
implying i can't be a real american with
some like that that's the implication
like you can't be an englishman because
you're black that's not what they're
asking they're just using an informal
way to be like what's your ethnic
background yeah you know where where do
your ancestors heal from yeah yeah and
they could they could they could phrase
it that way but i mean you know like i
look i'm clearly not an anglo-saxon okay
so if someone asks me that question
the notion that i'd be
deeply
offended and then i'll go go write some
twitter go write some twitter thread
about what happened and you know as if i
got assaulted or something yeah like all
the cops it's honestly it's embarrassing
and again this is what's been happening
again over the past year and a half is
people now have this inverted notion
that everybody else is you're
responsible for your health that's not
the case it's never been the case it's
never been the case you are responsible
for your own health does someone else
have a right to intentionally assault
you or like try to give you a disease or
something no that's that's a different
thing but go ahead not in california
california hiv things decriminalize that
that's so weird intentional spreading of
a disease decriminalized is it just hiv
or is it all of them i'm not sure i know
hiv was like the big story yeah where
they were like okay if someone
intentionally spreads it we're not going
to criminalize it
california is backwards man california
is so weird because
it's such a beautiful place such a
beautiful part of the world wonderful
weather and so on
but it's run by idiots like i can't even
put it i can't mince my words this state
and a lot of the cities are just run by
morons but is it incompetence at this
point they have a pool no no no the
copper industry is obsessively keeping
those wires all running through the
forests in california that are lighting
the wildfire i mean it is intentional
that they are living in a 20th century
infrastructure with 21st century
mindsets here's the thing
there comes a point where it doesn't
actually matter whether it's malicious
stupidity if you can't tell the
difference based on the results then i
would say there are certain situations
where it actually it doesn't matter
because the result the result is the is
the result right so if you
cause that whether it's whether you
tried to or you're just so dumb that it
led to this like if you're talking
forest these forest fires you're talking
like the mass homelessness problems or
whatever it is i'm like you know what it
doesn't matter because this is the
situation and the situation needs to be
fixed so either way whether you're just
incompetent or you're malicious
it doesn't matter like we need someone
else there i agree and that's why i
supported recalling i support recalling
newsome yeah and that's why i'm in favor
of larry elder winning not because i'm a
conservative larry elder is fairly
libertarian so i can agree with him on a
lot of those libertarian principles even
though i'm probably more i'm
substantially more left-leaning than him
on a lot of issues but the way i see it
is the system is so corrupt and
dominated by a one-party rule across the
board
getting anyone in there to challenge the
existing broken power structure would be
a godsend yeah you need to hold people's
feet to the fire right people often
forget that what their relationship and
dynamic between the people and
governments state representatives
federal representatives is supposed to
be it's not supposed to we're not we're
not in a dictatorship or a monarchy at
least we're not we're not supposed to be
it's not just supposed to be we've got
you've got supreme leader joe biden or
whoever a governor or mayor is or
whatever and everyone just
goes with whatever they say they're
supposed they're supposed to be
representatives and people often forget
that
we pay
we pay their salaries right the
politicians are employed
by the people they're not running a
business they're not directly creating
any value they're taxing us and our
money is literally going to their
salaries and i think we forget that and
i think certainly they forget that they
they get this notion that oh i i'm
actually just like a mini dictator
especially at a time like this where
they keep rolling these emergency powers
and i'm like look that's not what the
relationship is supposed to be you see
the same issues that can happen
sometimes with police as well right
where where that relationship
is not what it's actually supposed to be
right the role of a police officer is to
of course uphold and enforce the law but
it's to serve and protect the community
it's not to
threaten them or to assault people or to
like bully people around and abuse that
power and you know okay i've got my gun
whatever it's like that's not that's not
what that dynamic is supposed to be so i
think i don't i don't know how but i i
think there should be like constant
reminders of what
how how that relationship is supposed to
play out what's that experiment where
they put all those people in and then
they created like a hierarchy and they
gave some people like they were the
guards and the other stanford
experiments man and it went crazy like
the guards started just abusing their
power is that was that a real true story
though
stanford yeah it was done at stanford
university
yeah that's why it's called stanford
milgram experiments no no no no you're
mixing up two i think the milgram one is
the one with the shocks
yeah and stanford prison one is the one
with the guards
yeah it's two different experiments i i
don't have all the data on what exactly
went down but i heard stuff went
sideways yeah people went
tyrannical
very quickly to the point where because
it was supposed to be a role play but it
got to the stage where you know they
were actually legitimately abusing
people i love this idea we hear from the
left very often where they'll tweet at
you and say something like you would
have been on the side of the
confederates or you would have been on
the side of the nazis and all that stuff
and i'm like
there's this teacher who told tells the
story where he asks his students how
many of you
in this classroom would oppo
believe you would have opposed slavery
in the united states you know pre-civil
war in america and they all raised their
hands and he said okay now name
something right now that you will
publicly announce that is deeply
unpopular and get you ostracized by
mainstream society and of course they
don't they're they're all good little
followers and the point he was making is
that you know in hindsight we can look
back and be like oh of course we're the
good guys
but the fact is it's typically the
dissidents yes the critical thinkers who
are challenging the system and today
that's not the establishment left or the
the neo-con you know uh
never trumper types it is typically
some of the bernie people many of them
are just toeing the line for the
establishment left though but a lot of
the maga a lot of the conservatives a
lot of the disaffected liberals the
intellectual dark web types that are
thinking critically
challenging the the current power
structures yes so if you want to if you
think that you can go back in time and
you'd be some rebellious hero most
people wouldn't man most people are
afraid to even use their real name and
post their opinions on social media oh i
saw you post earlier today how great
your life can become if you expose
yourself online and become i was just
saying that people people miss a lot of
opportunities by by not doing so and i
mean i think it's a shame that so many
people live in constant fear and people
really really get upset when i use the
word cowardice but we do have a pandemic
of cowardice
we really do
um
jazz hands over here
i always feel kind of weird when one of
the things i hear most and i to me it's
kind of bittersweet is when people call
me brave when people like man zoo be
like you're so brave you speak up you do
it i'm like dude i just say stuff
i i talk when i think of courage and
bravery right if i'm looking at people
people in in the military going and
fighting on the front lines literally
putting their life at risk a fireman
running into a burning building to go
i'm like man that's like scary like
that's actually risking your life i'm
like man i say stuff on twitter i make
music i talk on podcasts i do publix i'm
like dude like okay
cool thanks thank you in a way but at
the same time i'm like man i wish
this shouldn't be that rare right it
shouldn't be that rare thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you